la semaine dernière à mayotte je dînais
dans une maison d'accueil de jeunes en
grande précarité voire en situation de
rue assis à côté de moi il y avait
giraud giro à 17 ans
ses parents sont disparus il est
accueilli dans une famille d'accueil
mais il est très probable qu'à 18 ans
géraud n'aura pas de papiers il sera
reconduit à la frontière alors que né à
mayotte il ne connaît personne dans le
pays d'origine de ses parents un mur
devant lui et jérôme me dit c'est dur
c'est dur pour moi je me pose plein de
questions
je comprends pas ce qui m'arrive
nous nous parlons et à un moment il
s'enhardit et me dit voilà est-ce que je
peux vous poser mes questions
la première question qui me pose c'est
est ce que je peux faire confiance aux
gens ici alors je lui explique pourquoi
la maison existe qui sont les gens qui
l'accompagnent et puis je me faisant ils
arrivent à sa deuxième question et sa
deuxième question elle me surprend un
peu parce que me dit j'ai regardé sur
internet
j'ai pas trouvé la terre qui tourne sur
elle même est ce qu elle tourne de
gauche à droite ou de droite à gauche
je m'y attendais pas je sors mon carnet
je fais des dessins et on parle du
soleil de la terre des étoiles
la discussion se poursuit et se
poursuivra toute la soirée après après
je je me suis mis à réfléchir et je me
suis dit finalement peut-être que les
deux questions dans son qu'une quel est
le sens qui fait tourner la terre quand
on a des jeunes comme ça
confronté à l'absurde total aucune
solution à vue humaine
et un océan de peur et d'effroi façon
c'est cela que je voudrais partager avec
vous ce ce christ désespoir
doit-on y répondre par un recommencement
d'histoire
mal parti ou faut-il réinventer restart
ou reset ma vie ne me mener pas à ce
monde-là à ces expériences l'argent j'ai
vécu dans le monde de l'entreprise la
grande entreprise la pme
et je suis arrivé il ya sept ans dans ce
monde de l'éducation de la formation
professionnelle au service des jeunes
les plus en difficultés des familles les
plus en difficulté
ça a été une sorte de big bang pour moi
et j ai découvert autant de autant de
douleur de souffrance et de tristesse
que d'énergie et de solutions et d'
enthousiasme pour l'avenir mais d'abord
il fallait comprendre
ce qui fait leur situation ce que sont
leurs questions l'an dernier avec
d'autres associations nous avons écouté
passé beaucoup de temps à écouter les
jeunes des familles des experts pour
comprendre quelles étaient les grands
déterminant de leur questionnement de
leurs perspectives je pas tout vous
raconter mais il y a deux
deux thèmes qui sont sorties en tête de
liste
la violence la famille
la violence d'abord c'est impressionnant
elle est omniprésente elle est
omniprésente et elle a de multiples
visages violence des jeunes sur
eux-mêmes violence des jeunes entre eux
violence des jeunes vers les adultes des
adultes vers les jeunes et elle prend
des visages nouveaux parce que les
réseaux sociaux lui permettent de se
diffuser sous des formes nouvelles
elle va toucher un élève dans une école
par du harcèlement elle va toucher des
jeunes dans les phénomènes de bandes
sur des sujets extraordinairement
douloureux et sensibles comme la
prostitution les addictions etc etc
pire encore cette violence elle
représente quasiment une voix inévitable
voire souhaitable c'est à dire que on
finit par croire que le seul moyen de
s'en sortir c'est d'être violent c'est
d'être le ford ans rapport de force et
la force c'est la violence quelle est la
conséquence de tout cela la violence
créer l'insécurité et l'insécurité va
consommer toute l'énergie de l'enfant du
jeune d'abord pour se protéger et donc
il n'aura pas l'énergie pour s'épanouir
à prendre s'ouvrir au monde créé des
liens de qualité et pire encore si la
violence vient des parents de la famille
des amis des institutions chargées
d'accompagner ces jeunes dans leur
épanouissement alors l'enfant le jeune
va se poser une question existentielle
est ce qu'il y à vraiment quelqu'un qui
m'aime dans ce monde deuxième thématique
la famille
c'est une image très contrastée de la
famille qui est sorti de cette écoute
d'un côté la famille est aussi un lieu
de violence on le sait maintenant dix
pour cent des adultes en france ont
connu un abus physiques sexuelles dans
leur enfance et dans la majeure partie
des cas c'est dans le cercle familial
que ceux ci s'est produit et pourtant la
famille c'est ce que tout le monde
souhaite tout le monde attend une
famille heureuse unis où les parents
accompagnent et aiment leurs enfants
vous voyez le tableau n'est pas simple
il n'est pas très beau et pourtant il y
a des pistes il y a des voix et je
voudrais revenir sur peut-être deux clés
qui permettent d'ouvrir des possibles
dans ce champ bien compliqué
la première voie
c'est la réponse ces situations de
violence et de l'insécurité
il est indispensable de penser
l'éducation de penser l'épanouissement
des enfants dans un cadre sécurisant
je les dis en insécurité l'énergie est
entièrement consommée à se protéger
donner un cadre sécurisant non pas tout
le temps et en toutes circonstances mais
au moins des lieux des personnes pour
accueillir sécurisé c'est ça la question
de jehro puis-je faire confiance aux
gens suis-je dans un lieu qui garantit
ma sécurité et dans lequel je vais
pouvoir enfin me consacrer à moi même et
à mon ouverture aux autres et au monde
la deuxième clé
elle est essentielle
elle consiste à dire que il est
important non seulement d'aider
d'accompagner mais surtout
d'accompagner ceux qui en ont besoin à
découvrir qu'ils ont eux mêmes la
capacité d'agir pour eux
les personnes en situation de précarité
n'ont pas besoin de quelque chose pensé
pour eux sans eux
on a l'habitude par exemple de dire il
vaut mieux apprendre à pêcher que donner
un poisson bien moi je dis il vaut
encore mieux donner envie d'apprendre à
pêcher parce que ça permet à chacun de
comprendre qu'il est lui même l'acteur
l'auteur de ces possibles dans sa vie et
ce chemin là est un véritable chemin de
construction c'est une transformation
assez radicale du modèle d'action
sociale c'est probablement d'ailleurs
aussi un changement pour toute notre
société
le constat est dur il y à des conditions
pour avancer et quand on met en place
cette sécurité et ce développement de la
capacité d'agir la capacité de penser
des possibles alors il y a des solutions
on voit des jeunes qui réinventent leur
manière d'être avec les autres et qui
redonne de l'espoir à leur entourage et
surtout à eux mêmes
mais peut-être le plus important c'est
qu'à ce moment là de leur histoire
c'est nous qui le rejoignent je vois ces
éducateurs
enthousiaste et joyeux quand un enfant
un jeune dit c'est grâce à toi que je
m'en suis sorti
nous sommes déplacés par ces mouvements
par ces
redémarrages par ces départs de jeunes
ils nous font bouger parce qu'ils nous
font penser que nous mêmes aussi nous
pouvons changer nous sommes toujours en
devenir
cette conviction qu'ils ont à nous
apporter je voudrais terminer par cela
et vous la partagez parce qu'il y aura
toujours des giro il y aura toujours ces
situations absolument inacceptables et
insupportables il faudra toujours pensé
inventé ré inventer de nouvelles
manières de faire et j'aimerais
j'aimerais vous avoir convaincus qu'il y
a des possibles et que vous avez votre
place non seulement pour y contribuer
pour aider mais pour vous-même aussi
penser le possible est l'avenir pour
vous